oh okay alright here we are on number
time alex says traveling with the
campaign's across Iowa affected your
opinion on whether or not Iowa should be
first in the Democratic primary let me
say one thing about Iowa cuz I think
this is unsorted unsung or and that's
unspoken there's the reason Steve King
is a congressman from Iowa is because
the demographics of Iowa are changing
there are a lot of immigrants in Iowa
some of them are undocumented some of
them are not but the the face of Iowa is
changing and changing rapidly especially
in the labor market and so we shouldn't
just dismiss Iowa as an all-white state
having said that it is pretty damn white
so so do I think that I mean I was
interviewing who leon castro this this
week and you know i think that there is
a reasonable argument to be made that
the party if it wants to accurately
reflect its electorate should at least
rotate around eight s-- that have higher
Hispanic and african-american population
what do you think panel of Trump saying
he'll go after entitlements if he's
re-elected [ __ ] what [ __ ] that
he said it I'm not gonna do it nobody's
gonna do it I mean this is what the
president says but why say it then
because he wanted more money from the
Republicans in his budget for nuclear
defense so they gave him more money by
saying we'll deal with entitlements next
time around and next time around just
like george w bush said he'll do it he
won't actually do it hmm
okay well really good about following up
on all the big promises there's no way
and even the Republicans a Paul Ryan
wanted this forever you've had both
houses of Congress and a Republican
president they wouldn't touch it it's a
when we finally go bankrupt as a nation
they'll all deal with these issues and
until them they're not going to but he
did not do well with that
I mean he's added like a trillion
dollars to the deficit it's horrible all
right I mean I used to remember I don't
even I used to be an elected Republican
for god sakes I have no idea what the
Republicans party stands for other than
humping the president's like these days
[Applause]
I've seen the other side it's you know
III honestly I said it's like God's
judgment I'm that I don't like the guy
and I'm there enough of his policies I
do versus the people who I really liked
Joe Biden he's a fine human being I
would sleep well with him as president
but the policies can I just show you
would vote for Biden over Trump I would
sleep well with Biden I know sleep well
if you could sleep wait wait if you'd
sleep well with them why couldn't you
busted III am I really life is a big
issue for me the life cause is and so
yeah all right so I was right about that
20 years ago the Democrats donor said
they would wipe out the Republican Party
if you had a pro-life democrat because a
lot of people don't like the president
will vote for him on this issue who
really don't even like the Republican
Party anymore at least at least don't
talk about abortion like you'll like it
there you know yes they used to know how
to do that better Clinton know how to do
it you know there's a good example same
thing with guns don't talk about it with
such a Glee you know like oh we're gonna
take all the guns and we're gonna by and
large the Democratic Party is not
running I mean bet about war can say
things on a debate stage but by and
large the Democratic Party is not
running around saying we're gonna take
away all the guns I mean no but they're
not running on a horse in either an
American but if you look at the polling
data this is not at the top of the list
but here's my thing Americans and I
Americans that's a Republican binary
there's only two camps now right there's
only two teams everything that the blue
team anybody on the blue team does gets
thrown in the blue team hopper and we
all have to answer for it so you're
right
not every Democrat is doing that but
when they make the ads the people in
Iowa will think at least the blue team
doesn't have as much to answer for these
days that's approved Ingrid how old
Trump's repealing of oh this is a
horrible story this week we didn't get
to Trump's repealing of Obama era water
protections effect animal populations in
the wetlands yeah now we go back to
dumping pesticides and fertilizers
directly into waterways and to destroy
wetlands for construction I mean this
has got to be a big issue for you yeah
we really can't point to any president
who's done magnificently for animals but
certainly this administration with who
they've put in charge of the Department
of Interior the Department of the sudden
the other that they're no friends of
animals one good thing has come out of
the Trump administration who did sign a
bill he signed a bill he also the EPA
has said it will move away from animal
experiments and we've been meeting with
them and they have come further in this
administration then they have
past administrations the use of animals
is good to go but no in any other area
it's been a disaster okay so I have one
last question I'm gonna quote something
in Eric I know you have really done a
good job but my night just I didn't get
to it during the the show but this is
I've read this before it's a transcript
of a recorded call between Paul Ryan
when he was the Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy and Steve Scalise right
this is June 15 2016 I didn't know they
were being taped but we've heard it
McCarthy
there's two people I think Putin pays
roar Becker and Trump swear to God
Ryan says this is off off the record no
leaks right this is how we know we're a
family here Scalise that's how you know
that we're tight
Ryan what's said in the family stays in
the family
so McCarthy says Putin pays Trump and
their reaction is not oh my god Trump is
on Putin's payroll it's yeah we keep
this in the family right that doesn't
bother you see I don't think you had
Rohrbacher I wouldn't be surprised what
he said the president is he said it I
think Putin tastes roll wrecker and
Trump swear to God just in case we
didn't I mean doesn't the specter of
that or the idea that history could
determine that in fact there was some
arrangement doesn't that whether paid or
not I don't know the facts on that and
I've been talking a lot about facts
we've heard that's that's what they say
but what really bothers me about folks
like this they don't like Trump they
talk like you I mean they all talk like
you they don't like the Republicans guys
I mean you know when they're they're
talking in the family that's what they
say among the family and yet when they
come out in the public right as they
care about taxes and for you maybe our
issues are maybe power they just they
just forget about all this other stuff
and that's what I can't respect I will
support any Republican senator
that gets up and says I've listened to
all the evidence and you know I wait for
my beliefs my opinion this president
shouldn't be removed because of this
what I can't stand is when they won't
let us see the facts when they they are
saying it's you know no I'm not I can't
hear the facts I can't hear the facts
the facts matter and and I'm optimistic
about America because actually if you
look at the data Americans care about
facts to most of Americans by the way
are not polarized they're purple we the
elites we the media we the Republican
they get the candidates because of
gerrymandering and money were polarized
Montana's not polarizing yes I want to
put you on the spot bill guess how many
Montanans voted for Barack Obama in 2008
in 2008 one tenant 43.8% oh you're
pretty close 47 Wow 47 tell me we're
polarized we're polarized
what we may be our polarized you're
optimistic
you
you